well back to our breaking news coming
out of Turkey and that military
operations have begun in northern Syria
let's go straight to simcha pseudo our
correspondent in Istanbul Reuters news
agency were talking about reports of
artillery fire and aerial assault in
that northeastern region what are you
hearing Sinan so turkish President Recep
Tayyip Erdogan just announced a few
minutes ago from his Twitter account
that the operation has started and what
we know with stats a Turkish Turkish
f-16 Jets took off from dr bakr turkey's
southern city and they hit wrestle the
YPG positions Syrian Kurdish fighter
groups positions in Russia line in Syria
also the f16 jets are supported by the
artillery and and we have been in the
pictures we see the smokes coming out so
literally technically the operation has
begun yesterday Turkish president soured
on said that the operation is to begin
shortly but no one would guess that it
would take less than 20 hour to launch
this operation and of course the
president tried to reassure as his
spokes people have over the past few
days the great care would be taken to
make sure that there were as few
civilian casualties as possible so just
confirm for us who is Turkey actually
targeting soil since the beginning
Turkey's rhetoric was this we target the
YPG which is the Syrian branch of the
outlawed Kurdistan Workers Party this is
what the Turkish authorities have said
since the beginning of the all the
crisis in Syria and Turkey has listed
they were the PKK as a terrorist
organization as the EU and the US has
has done as well so they say we don't
have any problem with the locals there
we don't have any problem with the Kurds
going there but we will not let at what
they call a terror corridor to be
established right beside our border we
which is like more than 400 kilometers
from the eastern side of the Euphrates
River to the Iraqi border
turkey says we will not let any entity
to be run by the YPG which turkey sees
as a terrorist organization the
operation targets of the YPG it wants to
clear the YPG from the region and
establish a safe zone of 30 kilometers
and Turkey plans to move back at least
one or two million Syrian refugees who
now live in Turkey back to this area and
of course that's the long-term plan
we're also getting news out of Russia at
the moment cinemas well that a senior
lawmaker there through Interfax
the news agency is saying that the
Turkish offensive in Syria can be
construed as a violation of Syria's
sovereignty is there a concern in Ankara
where the decisions are made that this
incursion would have embroiled other
parties that are interested in the way
that they control or do not control that
part of northern Syria so he'll actually
a Turkey's position in Syria in northern
Syria either northeast or Northwest has
been very complicated since the
beginning for instance like an hour or
more ago Turkish President how the phone
conversation with Russian President
Putin and according to the Turkish
presidency statement the both leaders
stated that this operation can be
constructive and it would open the way
or paved the way for a democratic
solution in Syria but of course the the
alignments always change on the ground
especially when it comes to Syria even
within a position or the opposite grips
for the for the PYD and YPG we we know
that Russia doesn't recognize them as a
terrorist organization and they have had
talks as well so for PYD or YPG it is
practical to align with Russia or
approach to regime when they have a
negative response from the Americans so
this is also a question mark for Turkey
as well and how Russia will react
towards this military operation has not
been very clear so far
so we'll try and from the Iranian side
we have been hearing that this operation
might be a step to violate Syria's
sovereignty but
has been emphasizing that turkey aims
only territorial integrity in Syria
which is also its border security and
its own territorial integrity but this
military operation might take long it
can take longer than expected because
the area that Turkish military targets
right now 30 kilometers deep more than
400 kilometers wide to the Iraqi border
is almost seven or eight times larger
than the former that the previous
military operations conducted in the
Euphrates Field area which covers album
jarabulus as and and offering the
operation olive range so it is a more
complicated military situation for the
Turkish military as well which will be
backed by the Free Syrian Army who merge
under a National Army by the interim
Syrian opposition government indeed
don't go too far away so they will be
coming back to you straight away because
they will cross over to Kimberly how
Qatar White House correspondent in DC
and of course Kimberly we were just
speaking earlier about this whole
situation it's very complicated
political and military jigsaw puzzle
that we see in Syria politicians and
certainly the Oval Office will be
watching very carefully about where
Turkey targets its military munitions
and its personnel yeah and it will also
be officials in the Pentagon that will
also be watching very carefully and
there will be deep disappointment with
the developments that we are reporting
on given the fact that the Pentagon has
been trying for some time to talk turkey
out of invading Northeast Syria in fact
in a pentagon statement that we had on
Monday it says that the Pentagon does
not endorse a Turkish military operation
of to Syria we will not support it so
obviously the advice of the United
States has not been heated in fact it
has been completely disregarded
something that we got an indication of
as early as Sunday when the White House
first put out that statement saying that
the US troops would pull back to make
way for a Turkish operation
it appears the coordination of Turkey's
leader air21 as well as president Trump
in the United States that these two
seemed to have been orchestrating this
unilaterally or bilaterally in the
absence of the advice at least of the
u.s. Pentagon now the Pentagon also
saying in that statement that it
released that there's the belief that
this is going to create risk for Turkey
and there's also the potential for
destabilizing consequences and getting
back to your initial question about
politicians you're right there are not
very many happy politicians with regard
to this this is a very divided country
politically has been for some time but
what we're seeing on this issue in the
US Congress is Democrats and Republicans
agreeing and that is rare the statement
coming from one top Democrat Bob
Menendez in the on the Foreign Relations
Committee in the US Senate he says that
this decision of the United States that
has now led to these developments with
Turkey moving forward with military
operations that this is up ending a
long-standing policy with an impulsive
politically driven decision that will
sacrifice long-term US national security
interests so the Pentagon not happy I'm
sure about this and we are reaching out
to see what information we can get there
but given the past statements from top
you know defense officials politicians
who are involved with the oversight on
that certainly there's going to be deep
concerned with the actions of Turkey as
it's moving forward but it can be sort
of this plays into much more than
long-term vision and influence that the
United States has in the region and
generally across the world because when
you have the former US ambassador to the
United Nations someone like nikki Haley
and Lindsey Graham a prominent
Republican who have been Trump
supporters both saying that you cannot
leave your allies your supporters in the
lurch like they have left the Kurdish
fighters when they've been fighting a
joint enemy in terms of ISIL there's
deep disappointment and deep concern
within the Republican Party and they as
a as two individuals of many will be
focused on what is being targeted in
northern Syria in the coming minutes and
hours
yeah the US president really tried to
underscore on Tuesday the relationship
between the United States and Turkey
that this is an important NATO ally that
there is an important partnership when
it comes to the f-35 fighter jet that
there is collaboration and the
construction of that and it's important
to support Turkey as a partner but you
brought up the former US ambassador to
the United Nations nikki Haley nikki
Haley very clear in one of her tweets
registering her displeasure with the US
presidents announcement of troops
pulling back out of Northeast Syria that
she she finished her her tweet with the
hashtag Turkey is not our friend a
direct contradiction to what the US
president has been saying and certainly
as we pull back from this even further
it is a confusing message coming out of
the White House because on the one hand
the United States is saying look at
Turkey as our friend u.s. President
Donald Trump has invited rechak tie-up
air21 to the White House on November
13th that's next month for a visit
underscoring this relationship but
there's a deep distrust of Turkey by
many US politicians in the US Congress
and certainly you brought up Senator
Lindsey Graham a Republican a member of
the president's own Republican Party who
usually is a very vocal supporter of
Donald Trump but on this issue not the
case he has been very much opposed to
this calling this a disaster there have
been suggestions that this is morally
wrong because of course don't forget in
the midst of all of this the Kurdish
fighters that helped the United States
in the defeat of ISIL working alongside
the United States for almost 5 years
even holding out hopes that with that
will come the promise of some sort of
autonomous control government region
nation all of that has been abandoned
and a number of lawmakers including
Senator Marco Rubio Republican have said
this is going to leave a moral stain on
the United States that the the
reputation with US allies will be harmed
not just in the eyes potentially of
the European community that has
registered deep concern about this but
but others expanding even wider that the
United States has moved ahead
impulsively for political reasons
perhaps motivated most in the words of
Donald Trump in his effort to win
re-election in 2020 he's very clearly
from the White House on Monday that he
made a campaign promise in 2016 to get
the United States out of endless Foreign
Wars and it appears that not just the
underscoring of the relationship with
Turkey but also keeping that campaign
promise is at the forefront of Donald
Trump's mind as he made this decision on
Sunday that has now led to these
breaking news developments of Turkey
moving forward with military operations
you keep a very close eye on what goes
on in the White House Kimberly and you
have your contacts there do you
generally get any sense at all that this
is a type of issue that the president
would roll back on me he has rolled back
directly on other issues but with one
that is so decisive important to the
strategy of how the Middle East is kept
safe do you think this is one that he
might really have to reconsider is he
that type of person he's definitely that
type of person the the only thing
consists of not consistent about Donald
Trump is his inconsistency so yeah
Donald Trump can change his mind with
the flip of a coin but having said that
we have already seen him twice pull back
providing extension for troops in Syria
after there has been registered
displeasure by the US Congress namely
the US Senate most recently we saw this
in January the president making a very
sort of surprise announcement as he met
with Baltic leaders the the US Senate
voting is displeasure and then suddenly
there is a bit of an extension many in
the US Congress hoping that will happen
a third time there is already an effort
president supporter Lindsey Graham a
member of his own public Republican
Party saying we're going to move ahead
with legislation to say that this is a
bad idea the problem with that there are
two problems with that number one any
effort in
lately in the Senate is non-binding so
the White House can continue to do what
it wants number two we're getting closer
and closer and closer to that November
20 2011 tensity and you can see from the
president's tweets that he put out in
just the last couple of hours that that
seems to be on his mind he's making the
case to the American voter when he wrote
on Twitter the United States has spent
eight trillion dollars fighting and
policing in the Middle East thousands of
our great soldiers have died or have
been badly wounded millions of people
have died on the other side going into
the Middle East is the worst decision
ever made and then he goes on into the
history of our country Donald Trump is
speaking directly to a domestic audience
there he is playing to the US voter that
has for many many years now felt
enormous war fatigue the the American
public feels it has been lied to with
the 2003 invasion of Iraq over faulty
intelligence that search for weapons of
mass destruction which were never found
and this is something that plays into
the minds of American voters American
voters know that the United States has
technically been at war in some former
fashion for a generation and that's what
Donald Trump is playing - and what is
prominent on his mind right now well we
know that you know getting too far
Kimberly will continue to get reaction
from you as the day progresses for those
of you that have just joined us you're
watching al Jazeera English live from
Doha a reminder of our breaking news
story this hour that the turkish
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan has
announced that the offensive into
northeastern Syria has begun a short
time he tweeted the Turkish Armed Forces
together with the Syrian National Army
just launched hashtag operation peace
spring against the PKK and the YPG and -
terrorists in northern Syria - being of
course ISIL our mission is to prevent
the creation of a terror corridor across
our southern border and to bring peace
to the area operation peace spring will
neutralize terror threats against Turkey
and lead to the establishment
a safe zone facilitating the return of
Syrian refugees to their homes we will
preserve Syria's territorial integrity
and liberate local communities from
terrorists let's cross over back to
Istanbul and to sinew Casula synonym for
our audience that are just joining us
let's just focus on who these terrorists
are as defined by the Turks and as far
as you're concerned where do we know
exactly where this operation is
beginning Sohail what turkey calls as a
terrorist group our first tip a YPG the
Syrian a Kurdish fighter group which
turkey believes is the syria branch of
the outlawed Kurdistan Workers Party PKK
and PKK is listed as a terrorist
organization by Turkey the EU and the
United States also what turkey calls as
a terrorist group is the isil turkey is
not only fighting the PKK in the region
but also fighting ISIL according to
Ankara and Ankara has blamed a
Washington for aligning with the YPG
which which is linked to a terrorist
group recognized by the US as well this
was a Turkish rhetoric since the
beginning but the Americans said that
the YPG has been leading a leading
troops of in the fight against ISIL and
according to what we are hearing from
the officials and their sources on the
ground there are explosion sounds in
Syria's vessel and right across the
southeastern cities on Olfa f16 jets
have taken off from a southeastern city
Dr Bakr and have started bombing the YPG
positions in wrestle iron also artillery
supporting the f16 a strikes currently
this is what we know so far in terms of
the pictures that Turkish television was
broadcasting just a short time ago we
saw areas as you say a dia baqia and
also tell a bad we've also been at our
chakali where our correspondent has also
been focusing his attention on the
military buildup in
of the way that the Turkish people have
been informed are they all on side with
this military operation what's the
general feeling there Sohail when it
comes to fight against the outlawed
Kurdistan Workers Party the PKK all
segments of the Turkish society meet on
the same ground because a turkey and as
the state a turkey has fought against
the PKK for almost four decades more
than three decades and it cost around
forty thousand lives both from the
Turkish military side and the Kurdish
citizens who have joined the PKK so far
so this is a long story for Turkey
economically Turkey has been very hurt
by the fight against the PKK during
those last decades that's why it is seen
as legitimate by the Turkish public of
course the the more the motive of the
military or the motive of the military
operation is appreciated by almost
everyone including the opposition the
way how the military operation is going
to be conducted was going to be
conducted was questioned by the
opposition or the supporters of the
government because there were some
parties even inside military who were
against the military operation so deep
and like 30 kilometers or more inside
northeastern Syria so motive wise yes it
is it is accepted and perceived well by
almost every segment of the societies
but of course how the military operation
will unfold especially thinking that the
US has taken out its support from both
sides neither from Turkey nor the Syrian
democratic forces side it's a it's a
little bit question mark indeed I mean
it's cinema will that support remain
there for her Diwan if he has and his
government have said that they will make
sure that the civilian population are
protected it whilst this military
operation happens in north eastern Syria
because once you have pictures of
civilians being injured in military
clashes
whatever they may be that can turn the
tide I mean is there a threshold to
which even the Turkish public would
criticize the government if they started
to see the injured being very back on
the Turkish soil where they are already
hosting several million Syrian refugees
already exactly so hey I mean when it
comes to the human it's a humanitarian
catastrophe it is there is no excuse for
this of course and the the PKK outlawed
Kurdistan Workers Party in general and
the YPG have used civilians as human
shields and whenever there is an attack
we can see on their web pages or media
outlets that they announced they are
going to use civilians as their human
shields so this is a concern of course
how the military operation is going to
unfold is a concern even though the
Turkish side claims and insists that
they are going to avoid any civilian
casualties of course when there are
eight strikes bombardments there are
some injuries that are unavoidable so
this is this is the very important issue
for the Turkish military I have spoken
to Turkish military members since this
operation news a broken Turkey had some
military operations elsewhere as well
Turkey has been in Somalia joined the UN
forces in Afghanistan and did operations
in in Cyprus decades ago and what they
tell me is that humanitarian safety is
the most important thing for the Turkish
military but of course the field the
battleground is different everything can
change there are some individual
incidents that you can point out for
instance the the YPG and the SDF was
reported by the international rights
groups as violating the civilian rights
injustice behaviors in the areas they
are taking they have taken under control
and they were those inter international
institutions have accused them for
forcing people displacing people
after they took control of the local
administrations however on the other
side there was a report again by an
International Institute that during this
Afrin operation operation Olive Branch
they the factions which joined the
Turkish military did some violations as
well in Afrin so this has this is a
concern for both sides Sohail and unless
the operation begins you you never know
what's going to happen but one thing
that I would like to say is that the
geography which turkey targets right now
is almost seven eight times bigger than
before the previous operation areas that
Turkey a handled like the operation
Olive Branch area and Euphrates field
area which includes El Bob Diablos as US
and other places and that area the
previous area was a mountainous area so
it was easy for the Turkish military to
conduct operation but this area on the
eastern side of the Euphrates River were
under SDF control this is a this is a
more kind of a flat area that's why
Turkish military experts warn that the
YPG forces will go into towns or
settlements which can a which is going
to be more like an urban urban warfare
so when it comes to urban areas it is
more important to avoid civilian
casualties because they're going to be
involved with the civilians